انطلقكم هذا رد موسكو على السقف الاسعار
الذي فرضه الغرب على خام الروسي المرسوم
الذي نشره موقع الكريم لان يحضر توريدا
النفط والمنتجات النفطيه للدول التي فرضت
هذا السقف على ان يدخل حيز التنفيذ في
الاول من شباط فبراير المقبل ويستمر لمده
خمسه اشهر مجموعه الدول السبع الكبرى
والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا كانت قد
اتفقت هذا الشهر على وضع حد الاقصى لسعر
النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل اعتبارا من الخامس من الشهر
الجاري ردا على الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
وفقا ما تقول الاجراء الذي لم يسبق ان جرى
فرضه حتى في اوقات الحرب البارده بين
الغرب والاتحاد السوفيتي يهدف الى شل
خزائن الدوله الروسيه عبر ضمان عدم قيام
موسكو بالالتفاف على الاجراء من خلال بيع
نفقه لاطراف ثالثه باسعار الاعلى موسكو
وصفات الخطوه الغربيه بالاجراء الغدائيه
والمتناقد مع القانون الدولي لكنها قللت
من اهميه
لقول انه لن يؤثر على حملتها العسكريه في
اوكرانيا معربه عن ثقتها بانها ستجد زبائن
جددا ومنذ بدات غزوه اوكرانيا يفرض الغرب
عقوبات واسعه نطاق على روسيا وبموازاه ذلك
يرسل مليارات الدولارات لمساعده الحكومه
الاوكرانيه